I'm Brendan Byrnes I'm an engineer on
the Cooper Nettie's team and we're here
in Google Seattle because well the truth
of the matter is that coo brunette ease
and container engine are powered by two
things one is a desire to make the
Google cloud platform the best place in
the world to run containers and the
other is caffeine lots and lots of
caffeine so in order to illustrate this
today we're going to have a little drag
race I'm going to turn up a cougar
Nettie's cluster on container engine
that's going to give us 160 cores of
container enable compute and at the same
time I'm going to make myself a latte
and we'll see who wins all right let's
get down to it I'm going to go over here
to the cloud console I'm going to choose
to create a cluster let's call it my
coffee cluster will do it in u.s.
central let's go a little big and we'll
have n1 standard 16 machines cluster
size 10 that's 160 cores and we'll say
start all right I'm stepping over to my
latte machine I'm going to get some
coffee going here we're brewing sleep
coffee today that's a local seattle
favorite pretty happy with that Brian
this one out that looks like that's
about enough smooth it out get my tamper
almost careful about this I'm never sure
I'm putting in the right pressure we'll
find out all right down on over there
and right now Cooper Nettie's is the
process of turning up the VMS to go
along with that it's installing the
community software on top of that and my
shot is ready I'm going to clear out the
portafilter not smell my espresso
alright wash that out in a second have
my limited edition Cameron Eddie's mug I
made that myself pretty proud of that
alright let's go going on so the longest
time actually didn't know that you could
turn this on and I'd hold it here and
steam burns all over myself it was
terrible but well live and learn that's
what I say alright so the crew benetti's
cluster is visually it's got the VMS
already created its busily installing
the software on top of that my milk is
filming along just perfectly and we're
looking pretty good all right take that
off there and pour the milk in that's a
pretty good foam right there of course
we're not actually done with the latte
right now I have to clean up don't want
out the legs person wash out our filter
yikes Wow wash out the Porta filter and
clean off the steam wand alrighty there
and put away the milk of course last
step in the law time making process is
enjoying the latte and there you have it
urban areas cluster up latte made 160
cores of containerized compute and a
delicious latte with delicious delicious
caffeine